welcome to the 2005 Carnegie Mellon
Solar Decathlon house originally known
as Pittsburgh synergy the house was
constructed by a team consisting of
Carnegie Mellon students students from
the art institute of pittsburgh and also
from the university of pittsburgh how
about we go into the house we're
actually entering what's the known as
the back entrance of the house some
people think of it as the front but it
gets a little confusing them that way
this is the south-facing side of the
house which is very critical in solar
powered buildings in that you want your
building to be oriented to the Sun as
much as possible to gain as much of that
solar exposure so as we walk into the
house you'll first notice that the house
is sort of made up into two main parts
the service corps which is the northern
facade and space over here two stories
and then this main south great room
these windows were put in place in
Pittsburgh they were not assembled in DC
so these beams that you see spanning
across the main great room actually
unhinge and bolt down into the floor to
create this very secure triangle that
was actually driven to DC on the tractor
trailer when we got to DC it was a set
the houses assembled so quickly people
were amazed just how fast we got it up
as one of the design features in the
house the team decided to go with these
sort of polycarbonate panels that is in
the kitchen we're used to put lights
behind them creates a nice sort of
atmosphere we have our encounter
dishwasher it just goes and pops up
there is a space saving feature and then
we actually have our induction cooktop
as we move into the bathroom one of the
key features of the solar decathlon is
anything you design that you plan to
include on the tour has to be
handicapped accessible there was
originally a curtain designed to go
around here so you could open it up when
you're not using it and then close it
off when you actually need making this
actually quite spacious bathroom in a
800 square foot house and this these are
the polycarbonate north wall panels I
was talking about but it's really nice
because they just sort of clicked
together and I believe there's two
layers of
here it's a real nice feature because
being on the north side you're not going
to get the sun exposure the other side
but amazingly this room even without the
lights on is still very bright and that
was another feature of the house we
really wanted to incorporate was a lot
of natural day lighting and this room
originally served as the bedroom for the
house and we had I believe a double bed
some furniture that was designed by
students and this room as well has the
benefits of the natural ventilation so
we're actually on the second floor of
the Solar Decathlon home and you can see
that students have actually gone and
after the competition of installed
sensors throughout the house in the 2007
house we're hoping to install more
sensors from the get-go so we can know
how the house is performing during the
competition and even serve immediately
afterwards the house actually has a
pretty high air exchange rate so we have
good air ventilation and good air
quality for that reason and you can
actually pan out sign you get to see a
lovely example of our solar panels hard
at work what we're looking at here is
actually the model for the 2007 Solar
Decathlon house the idea behind the
house is that it's modular so you can
start to adapt it to your needs in your
use there's the primary Service Corps
where all the utilities and waters are
help water features are held similar to
the 2005 house however the idea is that
you could go and expand it start to
expand it in other directions and the
idea being is that it's configurable to
your taste to your needs to your budget
so you can actually go and change that
and trying to not just make it a sort of
boxy shape we have this natural
integration of vegetation throughout it
but going and using that water that
falls and actually showing that the
vegetation can be integrated to the
building and we can go and mix the built
environment with the natural environment